[Music]
[Applause]
I'm J I'm
John love and
happiness banking card and marriage
registration something that can you
married yeah I guess we're
married
right they didn't bring up that we'd be
paed until the last interview it's an
old KGB tactic you draw us attention as
a
[Music]
couple very
romantic what is it that you two
do we software and Engineers administer
single dose no
casualties what you think if the company
had matched you you'd be compatible you
act sitting underneath a shelter I made
I made this fire I got shelter food fire
water no
maybe work life romance they're all part
of the same project you said you love
me yeah you did
too we're about to
die so you didn't mean it no I
do that's
cool
ow don't do
that
[Music]
sorry it's just a job it is not life and
[Applause]
[Laughter]
death you feel
[Music]
better